[Musique]
je m'appelle Kubo abrogeons
juatasha garderons l'unité de mémoire un ours venez
manger du lee baca un petit garçon un
[ __ ] de chef de drame Jamilah Nasheed oh ma
soeur seguido bikini faire grosse chienne à
Kahaluu pour combattre une chienne le géant
midget L veut le confort de la machine missus -
ah va te faire [ __ ] jamais
Kubo kid da Familia prend camo present
Lama su vida llamado presque rasullah
port-a-potty ji episod fuck team obese a
Toshio mais désolé Iveco akathisia fish
Sam tu vas t'asseoir sur moi  tu vas
très faisable il y a une décennie c'est notre
marché principal non défini désolé plus de yaourt
regarder Oscar pour voir la chair trad donde moi
oppa casino laponia pour Java
obtenir pour bien magie plus fluide s'il vous plaît ouvrir le
flux a fonctionné pour Miami [ __ ]
yo thon à Shia devrions-nous
hockety  pockety oh aucun effet d'inversion
attelage de remorque alicia Tamiko
ténèbres il est 12 heures
hmm toi Victor lèvre non non non vois
il suit Allah nepeta Picasso a roto
escape vraiment pour de vrai lundi
d'autres aviso di boy à Joe Pesci laisse
tout s  houes esq satirisées oh ouais Dietrich
sur Quora Satan cohosh an oppa Maria
[Musique]
parce que dans le film
tu
[Musique]
bientôt Appel Kubo impertinent immunisé
qu'est-ce que mashaallah doobly-doo livre est mon
panthéon toujours de l'eau
Vicki dirait bonjour oh c'est ça  est l'
origami est un maléfique et c'est vous
mr.  Connor
Libby booyah au Pérou emmy gee - tamati
texte emojis oh mon pauvre gars digimon
Fabrice Muamba Chicago Travis ml mon
koala
Devon ha - villa el sur - votre altesse
un aperçu une unité graine de pavot Emma voir la
traduction de Peter le touchet sont ici
Sylvie hurle emoji faire  un peu sauvage et si
vous savez que je veux vraiment vous concentrer sur votre décennie
c'est notre marché principal son environnement
Peppa enseignant apprenant loin les mots je
pense que c'est notre religion
ma devise Kubo ne sois pas grand juste il
y a ta chanson Saban poème qui me taquine aussi
info partir  de pecho nouvelle
paysannerie jaune aujourd'hui ou tu dis guac esto
pasa lumo à Hobbiton dépravé Urbano quoi tu cries à la
maison bein faire pour échapper
sc2 sampler moly dividend is tois
mijito tamati text emojis Oh
[Music]
Tami oh jesus Danny Fox / - désolé Kubo
yamagishi
si  un koala Navajo - Villar me L monsieur -
vous pouvez le mettre sur vous car Natasha se sent
subventionner le desta avisé que vous préférez
dissoudre notre installation de pommes de terre nominée,
il est un système de canaux d'affaires
sauf chez Anita kupo
darlin  g followers
Sifu Dovahkiin avait besoin de toi
Fick lumina
boom
oui Olympia saga secret une tentation
uber signifiait un coke wha CC flick Eva
veut quelques dents mo DC n PI sait Toby
air Kanye moi pour vraiment profiter DJ c'était un
obtenir un chic Michelle hahaha comment  scabby
[Musique]
vois ce plat marginal
c'est une histoire très mystique
un rite de passage de jeunes garçons une
histoire de famille intime jouée dans un monde épique
quel était le père Je ne pourrai jamais oublier
combien il t'aimait Coupon Kubo les deux
cordes  on dirait que c'est juste une
expérience incroyablement riche pour diverses raisons,
mais la raison la plus claire est qu'il
y a des monstres dedans
les monstres de Kubo sont évidemment une partie
assez importante et passionnante du
film ah ce qu'ils ont mis en évidence était l'échelle,
ils étaient d'énormes créatures nous
certainement  Je n'avais jamais fait ça auparavant
et je pense que l'ampleur de cela n'a jamais
été faite auparavant, mais le plus gros était
notre monstre squelette géant dans la salle
des os, hé, j'ai un os à choisir
avec vous
voyez être  parce qu'il est fait d'os tu es un
embarras dans notre monde ce serait un
monstre de cent pieds au début j'étais
assez nerveux et un peu effrayé
personne n'a animé une marionnette de cette taille
avant mais s'il était assemblé ce
squelette il pourrait '  En fait, dans
ce bâtiment, les monstres à Cuba ont
vraiment repoussé les limites de la
fabrication de marionnettes et de la technologie. L'un des plus gros
monstres avec lequel j'ai dû faire face dans ce
film était la créature sous-marine, quel
genre de chose elle a dit qu'il y avait un
jardin de  glace le jardin de I garden of
eyes are est scandaleux briller les globes oculaires sur les
tiges
il y a eu beaucoup de discussions au début
de ce qu'il devrait être à la
fin de ce qu'ils ont mis des boules de bingo et
une fois que nous avons décidé que le  le globe oculaire
devait être ce grand puits, ce qui signifiait que la
créature entière devait mesurer huit pieds de
haut.
ling ball
c'est certainement la chose la plus éclatante que
nous ayons jamais faite
si l'histoire va marcher les méchants
doivent être incroyablement dangereux et
terrifiant
Okubo le monstre le plus effrayant devrait être
la bête de la lune je pense que la bête de la lune est
la plus terrifiante qu'il soit vraiment  basé sur
un poisson préhistorique qui a vraiment existé et
qui m'a toujours effrayé, le
stop motion a un grand héritage
pour donner vie à des créatures, nous continuons à
le faire et de l'héritage,
j'étais définitivement une sorte de la prochaine
génération d'une certaine manière, c'est comme un Amash I
pensez - les vieux monstres en stop-motion mais les
nôtres sont meilleurs l'histoire était si bonne que nous
voulions vraiment la soutenir et la faire
sentir comme une aventure pour tout le monde
[Musique]
Je me souviens de cet avion
c'était là que mon père se préparait pour
sa quête
avec chaque  film que nous réalisons, nous voulons
faire quelque chose d'unique quelque chose d'original
pour raconter des histoires qui ne sont généralement pas
racontées dans l'animation, nous avançons dans
des directions différentes et Kubo est
certainement le film le plus épique.  ng que nous
avons déjà fait Je ne comprends pas cela Je ne
comprends pas Oh pour avoir pleuré à haute voix
en son cœur whoo bone les deux cordes est
un film de samouraï en stop-motion et au fur et à mesure que nous avons
commencé à développer le film au fil du temps, il
est devenu  quelque chose qui était bien plus qu'il
ne s'agit pas seulement de combattre des monstres, vous
savez, c'est une question de famille, c'est une question d'amour,
c'est une question de confiance, c'est un grand mythe.
devez-vous jouer avec votre nourriture oui
Kubo passe de sa vie simple au
grand monde effrayant là-bas et donc il
doit traverser ce voyage pour remplir ce
destin routier et il y avait toutes sortes de
défis en cours de route et bien vous savez
tout et ça  était trop ambitieux, mais
si quelque chose semble impossible à faire,
c'est normalement lorsque nous nous y
intéressons,
vous savez, un grand film d'action épique qui n'est
tout simplement pas quelque chose qui se fait généralement
en stop-motion et pour une bonne raison, comment
faisons-nous  stylets  ze water comment pouvons-nous faire
des monstres massifs émergeant de l'
ombre comment pouvons-nous donner
vie à ces personnages d'une manière qui semble réelle nous
n'avons certainement jamais fait cela auparavant et je
pense que l'ampleur de cela n'a jamais été
faite avant qu'il y ait quelque chose de si
transparent à ce sujet quand la technologie peut
épouser la narration comme ça, c'est vraiment
puissant, nous sommes maintenant ici à la fin d'un
processus de cinq ans et c'est vraiment un
témoignage de tous les artistes qui ont
relevé ce défi impossible et se sont transformés
en cet incroyable morceau de cinéma
vous